c'est le ils en pensent quoi votre frère
gossip est simple on arrête des gens
dans la rue en attendant qu'on les
interviews on part très très vite
s'habiller comme juste à côté
et voilà et enfin c'est bien comme à peu
près c'est pas tous les joueurs qui sont
plus on s'accroche derrière le plus
discrètement
aussi il ya plein de gens qui me
demandent avant de voir la séquence
karine sais pas si vous avez vu ça non
tout le monde en parle c'est
exceptionnel va ce qu'il fait il est
extrêmement drôle le le garçon il ya des
gens qui me demandent comment vous
arrivez à faire ça alors on va expliquer
où l'on sait qu'on a un très grand
portant incessamment fait un nom en a on
a un camion était garé à côté mais
vraiment injuste dehors de la caméra à
deux mètres de l'endroit et on a
quelqu'un toinou que j'embrasse kiki
commenté qui fait qui fait patienter les
gens leur pose en plein de questions du
temps que je me change très vite et
après on arrive derrière et voilà les
bergeries à personne c'est de la très
grosse production cette séquence qu'on a
beaucoup hésité avant la bête parce
qu'elle nous coûte bon costume notamment
et aux comédiens regardez bon ok c'est
bien et regardez bien qu'aux médias
dedans regardez c'est parti
qu'est ce que vous pensez des transports
en commun à part une madame je pense que
c'est tout le contraire de tout ça peut
être très bien où ça peut être pas bien
du tout ça dépend un peu des moments d
des types de transport grand et qu'est
ce qu'elle en pense votre sort oui non
moi je pense aussi pareil c'est vrai que
parfois c'est bien et c'est vrai que de
temps en temps peut être un petit peu
déçue quoi
question pensez des transports en commun
parisiens
qu'est ce que j'en pense qu'ils sont
bondés effectivement pour nous c'est
très différent et votre sorte que ce
qu'elle en pense pareil quoi finalement
parce que j'aimerais qu'on fait des
transports bon allez vous tout le temps
ensemble et c'est vrai que ça n'est pas
un petit peu des fois quoi qu'est ce que
vous pensez des transports en commun
parisiens
disons que par rapport à ce qui peut se
raconter en général l'occurrence c'est
vrai que
c'est plus cher mais c'est beaucoup plus
galère d'accord on fera en sorte parce
qu'ils ont peur zarbo badauds un peu
pareil parce que c'est vrai que bon on a
des soucis je suis d'accord je suis
d'accord mieux les transports en commun
et on est bien achalandé où y comparer à
d'autres villes européennes que je
connais ont votre or que son enfance
dorée taille parce que c'est vrai que
bon mais c'est là qu'on est celle à
paris nous sinon fioul à bruxelles
c'était pas mal rochelle oui posait
c'était bien mais le terek paris c'est
un type en tout cas les problèmes et que
gg
et j'ai vécu en plusieurs endroits du
monde paris excellente